Determina si la información dada en la tabla es un ejemplo de variación directa, inversa o conjunta.
Luego encuentra la ecuación que representa la relación.
Muy bien, vamos a empezar haciendo un pequeño repaso de qué era variación directa, inversa o conjunta.
Aquí le voy a poner directa,
voy a empezar con variación directa,
o bien con que las variables "x" y "y"
son directamente proporcionales.
¿Va?
En este caso, lo que tenemos es que "y",
"y" la podemos escribir como una constante
multiplicada por "x",
o bien, podríamos dividir entre "x"
ambos lados de esta igualdad,
y obtener equivalentemente que
"y" entre "x" es igual a "k",
o también podríamos hacerlo al revés,
podría ser que "x"... "x",
sea otra constante le voy a poner "k",
pero podría ser otra constante
multiplicada por "y",
y entonces aquí dividiendo entre "y" nos quedaría que
"x" entre "y", es igual a "k".
Otra vez ,a lo mejor no es la misma "k"
pero la idea es ésta,
que al dividir "x" entre "y"
o "y" entre "x", nos quede una constante,
y hay algunas pistas para detectar
que tenemos una variación directa,
por ejemplo, si tenemos que "x" aumenta,
como la variación es directa,
"y" también debe de aumentar,
en magnitud, ¿si?
por ejemplo, si aquí le pongo un 2
y luego lo convierto en un 4,
pues lleva a aumentar en magnitud.
Bueno, entonces si "x" aumenta "y" también aumenta,
si "x" disminuye "y" también disminuye.
Y otra pista es que si "x" la multiplicamos
digamos por 3,
o sea, si de "x" pasamos a "3x",
si multiplicamos por 3,
entonces "y" también se multiplica
por ese mismo factor.
"y" pasaría a "3y"
y de hecho esto se puede ver aquí arriba,
por ejemplo si la constante fuera 1,
y tenemos "x" igual a 1,
y "x" lo multiplicamos por 3,
entonces "x" pasa de 1 a 3,
y "y" también pasa de 1 a 3,
Muy bien, entonces estas de acá son las pistas
para determinar una variación directa,
vamos con variación invers,a o bien,
que las variables sean inversamente proporcionales,
inversa...
En este caso ahora la relación que tenemos es que
"y" es igual a una constante,
pero multiplicada por el recíproco de "x",
es decir,
es la constante multiplicada por 1 entre "x",
o también multiplicando por "x" de ambos lados,
lo podemos escribir como "xy",
"xy" es igual a "k".
Estas dos expresiones son equivalentes,
o bien dividiendo aquí entre "y"
podemos poner que "x,
"x" es igual a "k" por 1 entre "y",
todas estas de acá son equivalentes,
y nos dicen que "x" y "y"
son inversamente proporcionales,
y aquí las pistas son las siguientes,
aquí las pistas son,
que si "x" aumenta en magnitud
pues a ver qué sucedería,
si "x" aumenta en magnitud,
estamos dividiendo entre algo más grande,
entonces,
aquí toda esta expresión sería más pequeña,
por lo tanto le voy a poner entonces
"y" disminuye.
¿Vale?
esto es en cuanto a tamaños,
pero siendo un poco más concretos,
si "x" pasa a ser digamos "3x",
¿qué sucedería?
Pues si aquí en vez de poner "x" ponemos "3x",
estamos dividiendo
ahora entre algo tres veces más grande,
y por lo tanto,
esto es algo tres veces más chiquito,
es decir "y" ahora,
en vez de multiplicarse por 3,
se divide entre 3, nos quedaría un tercio...
un tercio de "y",
Muy bien, entonces esta es variación directa,
esta es variación inversa,
nada más déjame decirte, qué es variación conjunta.
De esta creo que no hemos platicado tanto
y no es tan común en los cursos de secundaria,
pero igual es bueno verla,
entonces voy a poner aquí variación conjunta...
conjunta...
y cuando hablamos de variación conjunta,
estamos hablando de más de dos variables,
de una relación de más de dos variables,
por ejemplo,
cuando decimos que el área de un rectángulo,
es igual a su base por su altura,
entonces aquí estamos
relacionando tres variables,
a "a" le estamos poniendo directamente
proporcional a "b" y "h",
y bueno,
la pista es ver 3 o más variables,
ahora, como en este ejemplo solo tenemos,
a "x" y a "y"
pues claramente no puede ser variación conjunta,
entonces podemos descartar este caso ¿vale?
Ya nada más nos queda variación directa y variación inversa
y para eso vamos a estudiar qué le sucede a "y" cuando "x" cambia
por ejemplo aquí,
"x" pasó de 1 a 2,
déjame usar otro color...
déjame usar otro color, este color rosa...
"x" pasa de 1 a 2,
entonces "x" está aumentando,
¿qué le sucede a "y"?
está disminuyendo,
2 pasó de ser 12 a ser 6,
aquí está disminuyendo,
entonces suena que no va a ser variación directa,
mira, incluso más todavía,
"x" se multiplicó por 2,
pero "y" se dividió entre 2,
aquí se dividió entre 2,
entonces no va a ser,
no va a hacer variación directa, ¿vale?
de manera similar, si "x" pasa de 4 a 1,
disminuyó,
y "y"pasa de 3 a 12, aumentó.
Entonces definitivamente no pasa este fenómeno,
y bueno como nada más son tres cosas,
y ya descartamos estas dos,
pues seguro, tiene que ser la tercera, ¿verdad?
tiene que ser de variación inversa
pero de cualquier forma vamos a verificarlo,
vamos a ver si sí es cierto,
pues veamos,
aquí no sé,
si "x" pasa de 2 a 4,
"x" pasa de 2 a 4,
entonces está aumentando,
se está multiplicando por 2,
y aquí la "y" pasó de ser 6 a ser 3,
en este caso, se está dividiendo entre 2
y está disminuyendo.
Entonces sí,
todo pinta a que la relación es una relación inversa,
entonces le voy a poner palomita,
pero para asegurarnos así, totalmente,
vamos a hacer la segunda parte,
vamos a encontrar la ecuación
que representa la relación.
Entonces como tenemos en mente,
que va a ser una una relación inversa,
el chiste es ver que el producto
siempre es constante.
Vamos a ver si sí es cierto.
Vamos a ver, que nos quedaría,
voy a poner por acá "x" por "y",
"x" porque "y"
qué nos quedaría en cada uno de estos casos,
si "x" es 1 y "y" es 12,
el producto es 12,
2 por 6 también es 12,
3 por 4 también es 12,
y finalmente 4 por 3 también es 12,
¡wow! ¡qué suerte!
Entonces el producto de las dos,
siempre es igual a 12,
es decir tenemos "x" "y"...
"x" por "y"
es igual a 12
y por lo tanto esta es la ecuación
que representa a la relación,
y ahora sí podemos verificar, que en efecto,
es un ejemplo de relación,
en la cual las variables están
inversamente proporcionales o
inversamente relacionadas
¿vale?
El producto es constante, bueno...